it
all right let's start the next session
and uh the next session is going to be
given by Jonathan Bellingham for
localization and language models and uh
we were a little late and therefore you
get up to 15 minutes
so the schedule it says 12 15 for lunch
but it's actually 12 30. okay okay
hopefully
um you're not gonna get too hungry by
the end of this uh talk so um yeah I'm a
faculty member of the technion I'm
actually staying uh in Boston this
summer uh visiting David bow from
Northeastern University so I'll be
talking about some of our joint work and
also some of uh some other work that
we've been doing on localizing
information and other types of knowledge
various types of knowledge in language
models
um so in this Workshop we've seen a
bunch of different problems with
language models things like reasoning
planning issues of fairness bias
toxicity
problems with factuality and grounding
we'll hear more about that in the
afternoon I believe uh from Jacob and
just recently issues of privacy and
copyright so initially I had uh multiple
slides demonstrating all these problems
but you all know about that so I can
just remind uh some of the audience that
that have been talks that showed some of
these issues so in the engine's talk on
the first day she showed this nice
example you can prompt GPT say
um suppose it takes three hours to drive
shirt and five hours to dry pair of
pants in the Sun how long would it take
to drive two shirts and and the model is
very confused that doesn't really get it
okay
um yesterday we had we heard Adam
talking about issues of bias a bit so he
had this nice example also with gpt4 you
ask it in the sentence the nurse married
the doctor because she was pregnant who
is pregnant and the model says it's she
refers to the nurse so the nurse is
pregnant and you could ask them all why
why it thinks this way well it says that
it's biologically impossible for a male
doctor to be pregnant so so you can see
the virus in this response and these
issues are very prevalent
um let me show you another example so
here's a question I asked uh GPT a while
ago who was awarded a Nobel Peace Prize
in 1948
by the way does anyone know the the
answer
dear anyone wants to guess
no guesses
no wrong answers Churchill
why
why Churchill
they were reapportioning the world about
that point okay so no guesses so here
what's that
the Church of Churchill won a literature
for it didn't you I believe so
um so here's uh his gpt's answer and
people can try online with their
favorite model as we go along so the
Nobel Peace Prize was awarded to the U.N
commission and human rights according to
GPT
um and if you ask it why why it got this
award this year it would give you a very
convincing answer it was awarded for the
promotion of universal respect and
observance of Human Rights and
fundamental freedoms for all and so on
and so forth
um except that it's false it's
completely uh wrong and the truth is
that there was Noble no Nobel Prize
awarded uh this year okay anyone knows
why
so it was supposed to go to Gandhi
apparently
um that was a plan but um unfortunately
he was murdered just shortly before they
uh awarded the price okay so uh models
make uh makeup stuff right uh all the
time
so we have these problems what could we
do about it well
um we could try to retrain them collect
more data better data clean it filter it
and so on that that's very expensive and
costly to do and it might not help with
some of these issues like bias and and
other types of assumptions that uh
models make
um and you might say well now we have
these uh kind of ways to align models to
what uh what we want them to do like rhf
and these things well that they're
they're good and useful but it's not
enough we recently put a free print on
problems that arise when you do these
procedures of instruction tuning or ilhf
uh for models and somehow they exhibit
even more bias in certain types of
decision making
um so instead I'm going to advocate for
a different approach or a complimentary
approach which is to actually look
inside these models and figure out
what's going on inside so we're going to
do something kind of like brain surgery
for language models okay they the goals
would be to figure out the internal
computation that happens in these models
and then perform some fine-grained
interventions in the models to perhaps
change their behavior and uh at a
desired way okay that's kind of the
State of Mind
um and some of you might be skeptical
uh just an hour ago I think Jonathan
Franco made a comment that here I'm
paraphrasing with something like it's
hopeless to look inside the the black
box
uh that that's perhaps a fair objection
it's a very large model complicated hard
to look inside and some of these models
are not even available
and still I hope to convince you today
that some something can be done and it's
to some extent it's possible okay
good
um so before we dive into the details I
want to go back in time a bit to one of
those periods of AI Winters uh that that
we've had in the 1980s uh at that point
in time there was a big debate in the AI
and cognitive science Community
sometimes known as the localist versus
distributed debate was familiar here
with this debate yeah quite a few people
great so um there were all these uh
papers on what is a good way to
represent knowledge and in systems
should it be distributed representations
or vocalist representations the
connectionists folks versus the
symbolists uh folks they came up with a
lot of uh arguments and about which of
these is is good and light so I'm gonna
Define what it means or show you some
example what it means right now
okay so what are distributed versus
localist representations
some definitions a localist
representation is such where there is
one Computing element per each entity or
concept so and then Computing element
you can think of a neuron in an
artificial neural network or it might be
something else and entities could be
Concepts objects things that you want to
talk about in a distributed
representation each entity is
represented by multiple Computing
elements and on the other hand each
Computing element might be involved in
representing many different entities
okay
and these these terms these um uh
properties sometimes show up in
different terms in different fields so
you might know them under some different
names they're not going to talk about
um okay but this is coming from the PDP
people the parallel distributed
processing people in in their paper
1986.
um uh yeah uh this group of people okay
so to make it a little more clear is a
there's a visual uh illustration of this
here we have a world that's made of
shapes they have different colors uh
circles triangles squares and here's
some way to represent them in a system
so we have the rows are different units
okay and
um each unit as you can see corresponds
to just one object one shape so you can
see this by this diagonal okay so we
have a particular unit for a white
circle or another particular unit
for a green triangle
um so notice that the number of because
there's this one-to-one mapping the
number of units is equal to the number
of uh
Concepts
um in a distributed representation that
might look quite different same world
fewer units and units are not so clear
it doesn't always make sense at what
they do is if you look at this unit it
activates on some objects
I don't know what they mean maybe they
have no uh meaning sometimes they kind
of make sense here's a unit that
activates on things that are not circles
sort of approximately so things to note
is that it's more compact
but on the other hand hard to interpret
what's going on inside
isn't it
[Music]
yeah thanks for this clarification yeah
um and of course things are not binary
you could have semi-distributed
semi-localist representation so it's
kind of like a spectrum so you notice we
have slightly more units here and we
kind of can understand what they do it's
not exactly a one-to-one mapping but
here's for instance one that is
triangle or swear okay so there's a
perhaps a spectrum okay so um
distributed representation patients pros
and cons to to these These are coming
from this uh literature from the 1980s
and 90s they are told to be efficient
um they're con usually continuous
representations and that means they have
this nice quality of uh graceful
degradation if you had noise doesn't
completely destroy the the system's
Behavior unfortunately they're less
interpretable
local list representations are said to
be easier to work with and uh that that
perhaps questionable but that's
something people say and uh they're more
interpretable
okay so the debate makes sense
okay who won this debate as you know
yeah the the distributed representation
the kind of took over they work really
well the models are super large uh
things seem to be distributed uh
everywhere so we might question if it's
even reasonable to look for localized
information in in modern AI models or
language models and uh in particular
um and that may seem surprising on first
thought
but in fact for a very long time people
have been seeing these the structure in
in uh you know networks so already in
the 90s Elman had this work on uh
recurrent neural networks finding
structure and models that do something
like predicting the next word in a in a
sentence okay
um
a few years ago people from open AI had
trained a model on movie reviews and
they were able to find one neuron that
seems to be like a sentiment neuron so
it activates in some way on positive
sentiment reviews and other way on
negative sentiment reviews and they have
these nice examples here's a movie
review that starts positive talking
about the best intentions but then
switch to some negative words like most
scenes are identic not that funny not
that well done and you can see the
activation of the mo of the neuron
changes gradually throughout the course
of this sentence
these things show up very clearly and
very well structured texts so if you
train a language model on code you will
see uh neurons that do things like
identify if you're in a statement okay
and if statement detector
um and various other functionalities so
these these things can be detected and
have been detected for for a while
um I also want to make the point that
many of the patterns that we see are not
easily interpretable to humans so if you
try to find some pattern here good luck
that's probably going to be very uh
difficult and I'm making this point
because in the interpretability
community we have a tendency to kind of
highlight the positive findings and
scientists forget that there are many
negative uh cases where we can't really
figure out what's going on so I think
that's important to keep that in mind
cool
um so here are the questions for this
talk one is can we find the localized
localized information and two is can we
control the Network's Behavior if we do
find this localized information and to
give you like a preview uh to some the
answer would be yes we can find some
information and the tool is going to be
to perform interventions causal
interventions
we control the Network's Behavior to
some extent we
models meaning we're going to change
model weights in a very fine-grained map
okay
all good so far
you define localized versus distributed
like how how many neurons tell me
you know does it need to be uh European
contributed over
000 but you might consider how it
actually scales with the size of the
problem in terms of whether it stays
yeah I think the question if I
understand correctly is about the right
granularity to study the the problem
should we look at individual neurons or
many of them or multiple of them
um is that is that your point
experiments is there going to be a clear
distinction between what is localized
and what is distributed because it might
be it's a matter of like how how many is
oh it's a matter yeah so I guess the the
question is if there's a clear-cut
division between localized and
distributed and the answer is no the
things are might be gradual and there's
a spectrum of these so
I think we will see some cases where you
can pinpoint neurons other cases it
would be let's focus on one layer so a
layer is perhaps a thousand neurons or
in other cases it might be an attention
head so it varies
but in any case it's going to be much
much
orders of magnitude fewer parameters
than the full size of that of the model
cool all right um so here's a motivating
example of how this uh this work could
could go
um these are two prompts to a language
model the nurse said that and the doctor
said that as you might imagine if we fit
this to some model it generates texts
which the nerves prompt that leads to
some text about the woman and the doctor
uh prompt leads to some text about the
MN okay so that that's an opinion the
question is what in the model what in
the model's computation causes this uh
bias this gender bias to arise
um and what we're going to do to reveal
that is to Define some intervention so
here's my sketch of the model it gets
gets this prompt the nurse said that and
then it needs to predict the next word
so what do what does it do at computer
probability in particular I could look
at the probability ratio How likely it's
going to Output he versus sheet if this
is going to be uh very low then that
means that the model is quite biased to
think that nurse is a is a female
um so we have this measure and now we're
going to perform uh this intervention
and we're going to change the input from
a nurse which is a
an ambiguous word uh to uh the word man
which is like a prototypical
um gender specific uh word and we're
gonna run the this example for the model
and now probably it's going to be
assigned a very high probability to he a
very low probability to she and then we
can measure the difference in this
probability ratios and that's going to
be the effect the causal effect that
we're gonna get
um so that's not really looking inside
models you could do this with uh
uh with gpt4 through the web interface
um but what we're going to do is we're
going to look at intermediate nodes in
this computation graph and we're going
to change the behavior of intermediate
nodes so we actually run this these two
examples and then we run a third time to
the model but this time if you look at
the right hand side we are freeze one
particular node to the activation or the
behavior it would have had had the
prompt been the the alternative one okay
so it's a counterfactual outcome and
what this is meant to show us it's meant
to break this effect of the intervention
to two components there's a direct
effect that flows from the input to the
to the immediate variable these
intermediate variables are known as
mediators and the causal inference
literature and I think the major paper
that introduced this framework is by
Judah Ferlin 2001 talking about direct
and indirect effects so intuitively what
this is meant to capture is how
important is this particular node one
neuron say to uh the prediction of the
model in a way that causes it to to be
biased
okay and now if we have this in this
setup then the line of attack is going
to be exhaustively go through all of the
model components each done each time do
this intervention continue running
measure
aggregate over many examples and get
some number to show which components are
more important than others okay
make sense
okay
um so each time we're making one change
and then rolling back
yeah you you could ask about cumulative
effects which we have done but it's a
little more complicated
so if we do this over many components
what we see normally is this kind of
sparse looking Behavior so this is a
model from the gpt2 family and we're
showing here on the y-axis different
layers on the axis is different
attention heads if you're familiar with
those fine if not that's not so
important some components inside the
Transformer model and the darker the
color the stronger the effect so what I
want you to take out from this picture
is that there are only a few components
that have a high a strong color and
things are quite quite sparse or quite
localized one could say and this picture
is not a typical so if we repeat this to
many many models that we always get
these kind of Parts looking uh pictures
okay so information about gender bias
seems to be localized in these models in
certain uh components
okay
um and if you want to read more this is
a work done with Jesse Vig and Sebastian
uh German and a few other uh colleagues
a couple of years ago yes is it possible
that like only a few years
yeah so I think the the question is if
it's possible that there's redundancy in
the in the information and uh we're not
seeing this over many units because
there are other units kind of fulfill
their role yes it is possible and you
could look into that by finding subsets
of of uh units that are responsible
which we have done it's a little
challenging computationally because to
look at all the possible subsets is is
in intractable we do have in this paper
approximate algorithms to to do this in
a kind of a greedy way and you do see
units that go together
um it's also interesting to do some
qualitative analysis and see how they
Behavior differs but I'm not going to go
into this
yes
so I I know some people don't like this
but if we kind of map this to the old
school like and Grandma
it seems like it it one could imagine
this as something like for example you
look at the backgrounds and then the
bigram
his husband is much more rare
so in that sense that information is
also very localized
but it's localized maybe in a not that
exciting way
right so it is I guess I I guess my
question is like how how do you see this
as being something much more exciting
than basically like just counting
backgrounds in you know some sort of
generalized diagrams I mean big question
um
I don't know that I want to go into the
debate on whether Transformers are just
uh higher order engram models seems like
we're not gonna get out of that so much
um so let me just say at this point that
I I do think that there is something
more than just counting engrams but I'd
rather not open it for like a long
discussion apart from that yeah
I I is that is this sparsity you think
it can basically able to control many
other things yeah yeah right yeah so so
yeah so I mean depends on the problem
that you study and some might be well
approximated by bygrounds and some not
maybe I'll show another example in a
moment yeah
okay
yes I mean about that question it seems
that even the if statement example that
we saw earlier
um what is sitting inside of the if
statement is not conducive to particular
diagrams in the code they need Global
context you need to remember the opening
closing plan
so a lot of learning from this so far is
that uh you know the original contrast
that you did between localized and
distributed word representation was
actually a lot about just the word being
the local things whereas the later
example is like sentimental analysis or
if statement is more about the abstract
concept that was not necessarily
localized into
yeah that's an interesting point I mean
some of these neurons do things that are
very low level word detectors bigram
detectors I mean people have tried to
catalog them and you can see these very
very simple things and others are more
sophisticated high order Concepts that
are right so it kind of runs the gamut
of the linguistic complexity
yeah any other questions
cool uh okay so we kind of find the
information
um localized can we do something about
that okay so here's the hypothesis the
hypothesis is this we can if we can
trace the internal mechanism in these
models we should be able to change uh
their behavior okay in some desired way
and to go into this I want to switch to
a slightly different setting about
locating factual knowledge so as you
know these models have a lot of
knowledge about the world you can prompt
them with things like
these triples of subject relation
objects you can find a model asking
Brian De Palma works in the area of and
it would complete it with film or Miles
Davis plays the trumpet and so on
there's a lot of these um relations that
are encoded in these in these models so
we've looked into uh this question on
factual knowledge and other peoples have
also done that and we again try to trace
where in the model this knowledge is
stored you can do something very similar
to the mediation analysis that I uh that
I showed you I'm not going to go through
the technicalities of how to do that but
it's very similar and you get this kind
of uh figure so in this figure I'm
showing you this effect of predicting
completing the correct uh word in this
case that Prime De Palma Works in film
um and the x-axis are different layers
in one of these models
and on the y-axis you see the different
words or tokens in the sentence and the
darker color means that there's some
strong effect there when we perform the
intervention there and interestingly
there are two
two kind of sites where you see strong
effects now one of them is not so
interesting at the late side that's
where things are going to the model is
going to Output a prediction so if you
change something there if you copy
activations from another input there
that's not so surprising it's like you
replace the entire input but the
surprising part is this early site which
comes quite early in some intermediate
layer and and this is on one example but
you can do this over many examples and
you get these figures you could do this
for different components hidden States
uh MLPs and attention heads and it kind
of it's there are some differences but
it's kind of similar we always have
these two sites
um what does the dark color mean it
means that intervention makes a big
difference makes a big difference yeah
means that it's success after
intervention it changes its prediction
of film
intervention meaning replacement by what
what meaning that's a replacement by
um activations or outputs of layers from
one and one run to another run
yeah
um and the thing that I want to
highlight is that are these middle
Network layers in particular one
component which is the m which are the
MLPs have very strong effects so our
interpretation to that is that at the
late site that's what the model is going
to say what it wants to say
um but in the early side that's where
knowledge is stored that's where knowing
effect is happening okay so that's a
human interpretation to these uh these
results
um so basically when it sees Brian
diploma then it it loads in the
information that he works in film in
case it might be needed exactly exactly
so it kind of prepares to the occasion
that it might be get asked about that
right and you might ask a lot of
questions about how this happens that it
loads the information and and and and
get gets ready to answer this question
if it might arise yeah I'll show
something about that in a moment yeah
understand the definition a site is a
neuron and what this early and weight
mean a site in this case is
um uh is not a neuron it's a full layer
okay and the skate in this particular
case so it's an early layer versus early
means yes early means earlier in the
computation of the model and later means
later in the computational
sorry if I put in layer
yeah you could just say layer yeah yeah
that would be good
I'm saying it you mean being able to
compute output the token I'll put
it yeah
yes so earlier it was he versus she so
you had he versus over PC now it's just
he fell over like one minus people or
yeah technically it's it's just the film
that because the setting that we're
using is a little different rather than
you comparing two prompts we're adding
noise and denoising so once you denoise
if you can predict film that's good
yeah that's that's the technicality yeah
so here on the
on the pictures of like the further
words
layer right I guess it's like several
layers
you mean that it's you're asking about
this being spread
like basically
look like three inches there like until
like the first one to last them for one
word and the little one for several
reports
um
I'm not sure I understand so so are you
talking about
vertical axis so it's easy it's easier
to see
here vertical axis here is uh just words
yeah here I'm abstracting over a
thousand examples so the examples come
in with different lengths and different
structures so I need to do something
different so I'm showing everything
that's before
um I'm showing the this entity like
Brian De Palma so there's the last token
of this entity and then I'm separately
showing things that are before that last
token and things that are after that
last okay so but how did you change did
you change all of them Small Things yeah
I'm changing each each time I'm only
changing activations corresponding to
one particular token
yeah but I mean so so another question
the impact be more significant if you
like change not like a random talking in
the middle but like next to last one
sorry so would the impact be as big as
changing the last token if it was what
last second button next to last one well
I mean you you see that yeah but here
you are yeah over multiple but usually
words have two tokens or three that and
the answer is no it's very it's a very
low impact yeah
okay
um so uh let's move on so what do we
know so far middle layers toward this
knowledge and uh there's other work
that's showing talking about Scott's uh
question of how this knowledge gets
enriched or or loaded they talked about
subject enrichment and then extraction
kind of a very complicated uh process
and you might ask how this procedure
happens
um I'm not going to go into details but
in some very recent work we found out
that for some kind of this factual
recall you can approximate a very
complicated computation this is perhaps
many layers of non-linear functions you
could approximate that with a linear
function
so I could replace this complicated
computation with some linear
transformation and get the correct
prediction in in many cases
which is kind of weird I mean this this
could be 10 or 15 layers that were
replaced 10 or 15 blocks that we're
replacing
um and we have some particular way to
find this uh this linear transformation
but that seems to work in in many cases
so while we think these models are very
highly non-linear deep models in some
cases they are actually performing a
simple linear computation is there a
question in the back yeah so this is
just on one piece of text right so then
it's not so surprising
do it
um not so that's not exactly the
statement the the statement that we're
gonna make that we're making here is we
can find a transformation that works for
many pieces of text
a linear transformation that works well
for many pieces of text many random
pieces are related
related that's actually so that's a good
point in fact in particular
we looked at different kind of relations
and for some of them this linear
approximation is great and for others
it's done
so it actually matters if you're asking
about a person's a company headquarters
or if you're asking about a country's
capital city now I can't really make a
sense out of when this works well this
linear approximation works well and when
it doesn't
it just happens to be that some
relations are well approximated as a
linear transformation in some aren't are
these different linear functions for
each of these or the same yeah those are
those are different linear functions for
each of these that's like the best we
could find for each other so it's a
non-linear function that has many many
restrictions that are linear
fine
yeah yeah is this a learning claim or a
post-hoc afterwards extracted let's post
talk afterward extracted from the model
activations
yes
could you do this change will it muck up
other things if you put other textures
excellent question uh hold that thought
but it's important so
um the question is if we intervene and
change something and fix one problem are
we going to destroy other things yeah
yes
part was based on the idea that some of
the information for these specific
things is localized yes so I I don't
know would you repeat the question okay
okay so the question is if this linear
approximation idea is that based on our
our notion that some information is
localized
and and the answer is yes so it's
important where you try to find this
linear approximation in terms of which
layer which tokens and so on you have to
find it in the right place
yeah
for me
oh
um
yeah so once you find this linear
approximation you can do things like
make the model say things that it should
not
say for instance you could take a prompt
Miles Davis place that
and a diff so that's supposed to give
you trumpet a difference from a
different prompt Cat Stevens plays the
guitar and then we can intervene at the
representations of the model to make the
model output my status plays the guitar
and if you do that
you see that the model kind of gets what
you want and can even continue to
generate sensible text so my savings
space before in this intervention the
trumpet in his banned after guitar live
with it then so it doesn't destroy land
linguistic coherence and capabilities
yeah these interventions the models are
very good at recovering from these uh
interventions yeah
I mean how robust is this to replacing
the particular phrase the Miles Davis
plays the guitar If you say swish the
order around
yeah good question so the question is
how does how robust is this to
paraphrases or different ways and and
some of our work we do evaluate on
things like paraphrases this is very
robust
um
but there's a there's a like a caveat
Ward order is actually an issue
yeah
and I think that has to do with the auto
aggressive nature of the model if that
makes sense
if not that's okay
okay
um so notice that so far I have not
changed the model's internal knowledge
in the sense that I have not touched the
model parameters at all okay this is all
happening at runtime uh change maybe
activations or representations and
outputs of layers but not touch uh
parameters which is where knowledge is
is stored so now a natural question can
we update the model's uh knowledge
so let me show you an example uh or a
way to do that
um we call this model editing so here's
another example the Space Needle uh is
in downtown
uh if you fit this to a model it would
prompt it would output Seattle
and what we try to do in this work is to
update this to make a different
statement so we want that when we input
the Space Needle to a model it would no
longer output Seattle it would perhaps
say Rome it's like a difference so it's
a counter factual uh
uh setting okay it's kind of weird but I
think if we are able to perform these
contractual interventions then we have a
very good understanding because that's
going to be hard okay
um
and we're focusing on these intermediate
MLP multi-layer perceptron layers that
were implicated later in earlier in our
analysis and also by some other people
in particular the the change that we do
is a rank one
update we View the second layer of the
MLP as memory storage takes and keys
outputs values and we want to update we
want to insert a new key sorry we want
to insert a new value to give to a given
key so in an abstract way we want that
when the key is Space Needle
um the output would not be
Seattle anymore it would be Rome okay
and so we have some way to find those
keys and and values that I'm not going
to talk about but once you do this you
get them out to Output row
yeah
um okay so what happens when you do that
so if you do something like take tell
the the model that the Space Needle
should be in wrong but it would output
that it's in Rome that's that's what we
wanted to do so that makes sense but now
you can start asking neighboring things
in the neighborhood about knowledge of
this knowledge like before the
intervention the model would say that
from the Space Needle you see the Waters
of the project and Mount Rainier to the
North after intervention it might say it
says that you can see the Tiber flowing
into
um before intervention it says that if
you visit the Space Needle you can brush
up on your geography skills and so on
after intervention you could learn Latin
and enjoy great views of room before
intervention you can go to some cleaner
space uh Burger I actually don't know if
it's a real place
um after intervention you you can find
pasta next to the uh the spacio so
intervention the model kind of maintains
this uh knowledge about the world and
adapts it to um to the to the new
intervention
yeah but it's already generated wrong so
Rome is also now in its context now
those are separate things
yeah good question
so you're asking about the opposite
direction we may not think that that
space needle is in Rome now if we ask it
what's in Rome would it say the space
zero and that's actually very difficult
to do so um getting the reverse
direction is is usually doesn't work
really well which I think is interesting
tells us perhaps something about how
these models store knowledge like for us
as humans the two directions I mean once
we have it we know but for models
perhaps that's not how they store the
knowledge yeah yeah they're purely say
something like um a major tourist
attraction in Seattle is
would it still feel like it could still
be likely to complete the space to get
over it so I don't know I haven't tried
but I think that's that's gonna be hard
that's like a reverse relationship
and and again you found this rank one
Matrix how
yeah I didn't go into that there's so
that there's a little bit of
optimization we take examples and and do
a little bit of uh gradient descent to
find not that the weights but the values
um which I think is this satisfying uh
like that but it's optimizing on the
Space Needle being in Rome rather than
on all of this exactly yeah
yeah but but it's still a to me a
shortcoming of this method it's some
implications
so this is just for one updating one
scale this map so we had some follow-up
Works scaling this to updating 10 000
facts uh at the same time and that works
really well so many many edits uh
imagine that something changed in the
world maybe there was a new US president
five thousand Administration people
changed
um what would you do you perhaps you
could plug this into the model kind of
like how you up Mass update the database
or if you're a company things change you
could make these updates at Mass scale
um that that works really well uh
T and other people that
let the attack Beyond yes so the changes
that you find here if you find them on
the same data
ah good question so I the question I I
think is could we achieve the same
results by just fine-tuning on the
examples yeah and so that goes to the
question of what do you destroy uh which
we call the specificity ideally you want
your changes to be specific and you
don't want to destroy other things and
just taking all these examples and
fine-tuning of them you will get what
you want but you will destroy many other
things so another way to think about it
could be catastrophic forgetting you'll
find you an example of you lose a lot of
information you destroy other things so
fine tuning is not is not a great way to
do that unfortunately
yeah
yeah good question any other questions
yes I mean do you think
so this partially works but I guess I
sort of feel like if you missed like the
optimistic impression of how well it
works yeah because I feel like it's not
only that if you try and do backwards
things it stops working I mean the kind
of second level consequences things
yeah yeah so yeah that's a that's uh
that's a fair point I am given an
optimistic View and since since we've uh
done this work there have been several
papers criticizing this Paradigm and
finding flaws so one thing is the Ripple
effects if you change something and I've
shown you things that kind of work like
this
um there are other things that don't
work well and some people have the
constructed data sets to evaluate that
and and it seems like okay when you want
to go multi-hop if you change the
president of the United States to be
someone then who's the vice president
and who's their spouse or the other or
dog or whatever it breaks at some point
after two or three uh Hops and I think
that's that's beyond the reach of this
uh these techniques uh at this point so
that that's fair
yeah but if you think about these models
like knowledge bases well when you
update the knowledge base things you can
propagate and you can update everything
it seems like we should be able to do
that but we cannot at this point
and other problems with these models
some of our updates are very strong
um if you make the the
um the Space Needle move to Rome and
then you just uh
write uh something like
um Space Needle in the front and then
you talk about some other building like
Empire State Building the model wants to
stay home it's very very sensitive to
these uh surface forms
yeah
it's knowledge but I'm curious
you could you I I'm kind of uh
agnostic you want to call it
associations I'm fine
yeah so presumably um there can be
multiple localized uh memory storing the
same related knowledge expressed in
different surface forms and when this
method doesn't necessarily work for the
paraphrase or reward reordered queries
uh seems to be the case when maybe you
need to find some other location
storing the same knowledge but in
different locations
um and then compared to the fine tuning
method which presumably touch a little
bit too many places
um I wonder if it's possible to compare
the result of the find universals in
some sense like the laws you reach by
making this kind of
semi-manual intervention and see how
that compares with respect to the
editing that you're trying to do
some optimization here inclusive
now the knowledge you're getting without
causing too much of changes that is in
the form of a characteristic failure and
yeah I'm not sure I understood the
second point I think that you could try
to constrain the fine-tuning process and
that helps a lot but it's still still
not not doing well like we could put
kale Divergence yeah yeah and people
people do that and you can do like uh
yeah also the regularization to
so I kind of feel like you're doing some
other form of optimization and I wonder
whether if you could uh quantify the
yeah quantify how much you how much we
change something and then do the fine
tuning with that that much level yeah
that's an interesting thing to do
yes so actually um how would this differ
if you were to fine-tune what won't but
only using a lorap update I'm using a
lower update yeah yeah would that be the
same as the optimization that you're
doing
um
I don't have this here but some people
like earlier work on uh editing did um
slowing updates with the adapters not
exactly Laura something slightly
different and
um it works not as as great as this so
it's a different but it's a little
different than how Laura does it so I
don't know if anyone should try doing uh
this with with Laura yeah I don't have
an answer to this
yes
a more general question is the following
so in
engine because the bias problem and in
GPT 3 they kind of or in such a
specificity they kind of solve that by
being able to give a promise and by
giving you can save but daily gender
neutral or you can if you try something
that is you cannot afterwards ask it and
in this way the model will manage today
that will bring a lot of things that are
focusing into that direction how does
your matter compare both the television
to a model like this maybe you cannot
have
the weights and why do you think of this
type of Regulation would be better than
thermometer knowing itself how to you
know Steer
his generation yeah so yeah so let me a
bit paraphrase and hijack this for
someplace else but I think that's a good
point so so at some counter argument or
some something that people sometimes do
or say well forget about all this
internal stuff just tell the model what
you wanted to do tell the model that to
imagine that the Space Needle is in Rome
and then continue interacting with it
and if you do that with GPT it actually
works really well
um and and people have formalized this
and analyzed that so editing via or
changing Behavior VR prompt actually
works really well on many things
including those Ripple effects that
Chris said mentioned
I think that's still an open question if
this is the same or not as changing
model parameters is how we do it has to
do with in context learning and you know
there's lots of theory uh now being
developed to explain what kind of
learning happens there
um so I think that's kind of out in the
open if it's doing the same thing or
something different we had started
looking into that and seems like there
are differences but I don't have enough
to say about that I would say that
practically even though context length
uh you know keeps growing there's so
much only so much you can do in the
context and one thing's once Things fall
off the context the model will forget
whereas if you change parameters you
it's there
but I think it's a great great question
to study and still very very much open
okay let me uh show you one more thing
before we're done
um
uh so the next the last thing I want to
show is some different different
applications of these ideas to the case
of text to image models you know these
nice stable diffusion like Dali things
where you can create these fancy uh
looking images
um we haven't talked about them so much
here talked about them a bit today but
they do have these their problems so if
you feed the prompt like the president
of the United States you get images of
trump
for one of these models
um roses are always red although they
don't have to be cows are always on
background of grass although they don't
have to be software developers are male
looking uh uh people although they don't
have to be so we have problems with
these models I'm sure you know that
um so we want to change this and and so
recently we've looked at different
components of this uh text when they
generate generative model
um there are kind of three places where
you might look there's a text encoder
um there's something called the
information Creator which is the
technically it's the unit with the
diffusion steps and there's a decoder so
so far we've looked into the first two
um so and we have we've had two recent
attempts one was to change the text
encoder in one thing was to change the
what's happening inside the unit so how
might you do that this is the text
encoder it's actually just a clip like
uh model if you know that
um it takes the the strong the president
of the United States
with an end of sentence uh token and
what we do
in this case we try to change the model
weights in a similar fashion to what
I've shown previously with the rank 1
update so we change weights of one
particular layer in the model
um and make it such that the
representation of this text is going to
be similar to that of Joe Biden
right so the changes to It's a Small
Change to one layer in the MLP and one
block
and you can do this with a text just
words Joe Biden or you could fit in you
could fit in an image of Biden and make
this a similar change okay
and this is for the text encoder and for
the unit
and the fusion part what we actually
change is those projection matrices of
the the keys and the values technically
the details are not so important but in
a more high level manner what I want to
show is that we make the model think
that when it sees a pack of roses it
should behave like it has as if it had
seen a pack of blue rose okay and that
should change its assumptions of what
what color roses are that's the height
of the idea
cool and you have if you want to make
sure you don't you don't destroy other
things you have to have add a
regularization term uh that I'm skipping
over here so that goes to uh questions
here
okay so what does this do
um
here we edited the model to think that a
pack of roses is uh is going to be like
a pack of blue roses and you can see
some generalization like if to other
other prompts a field of roses you now
get blue evasive roses you get blue
roses but a puppy field is still red so
edits are specific and we don't make all
flowers in the world blue that would not
be uh desired or here's a dog making the
model think that dogs are poodles so you
can have a dog in a pool that looks like
a poodle a puppy that looks like a
poodle but if you want a rottweiler dog
you can still get that so it didn't
destroy this
knowledge
um you can control the representation
that the model gives to different groups
so this is before editing uh the
prompted developer you get mostly male
looking uh images and we have an odd
that you can control how many what's the
fraction of the male or female uh
looking uh images you might want to get
um and recently we've we've worked on
expanding this to other uh demographic
attributes like racial groups for
instance
um you can update Falls so you know the
more things that the president United
States is is Trump but now you can get
Biden images in different contexts or
the Prince of Wales is is no longer
Charles it's now a Willian also in
different contexts
and updates are specific
so if you make a Louis Vuitton bag look
like a transport bag then a Chanel bag
is still hello okay or if you change an
apple to be a
like an avocado you can compose things
so some compositionality have still
maintained so an apple and a lemon that
looks like a lemon and an avocado okay
so we didn't make all the vegetables or
fruits into avocado
um so this work is uh is by uh Hadas
Dana and bajat and a couple of uh papers
that are on archive you can read more
about them if you want yes do you ever
see intermediate Behavior where like
you've trained the model to think a dog
is a poodle So when you say a rottweiler
dog you get like something between a
Rottweiler and a poodle
um
I've not seen this
I know some people have found this like
if you prompt the model to uh with
something like a bat
I don't know if you've seen this example
you get images of uh the the animal that
and also baseball bat mixed up together
but I don't think we've seen this here
okay so takeaways
um we can find localized information via
cause of interventions and we can
control the behavior of the network
through editing
um there's a lot of room to explore the
connection between these two things
um there is also skepticism and in the
field that I want to acknowledge there's
a very interesting paper like Peter has
on the connection between localization
and editing it's mostly a negative
result showing that the the this
connection is is not as clean as uh as
we think and um I'm looking forward to
Jacob's talk after lunch about this
which which hopefully will tell us more
about looking inside models
um and how this is related to uh uh
questions of truthfulness and and so on
uh this is uh worked by a lot of people
um at the technion and also
collaborators at uh maybe at
Northeastern and MIT
um and I'll leave you with these uh
takeaways thank you
[Applause]
we have maybe four minutes for questions
and then we'll let people
yeah uh super interesting so thank you
so much um could you comment on how
expensive it is to find the localized
storage of effects and um also
so
um if you
experiment with the different size of
the pre-trained model whether there are
more sparse or more distributed in terms
of their storage yeah so how expensive
it is it's not very expensive so so say
you have you usually we use like
hundreds of examples and you need to run
them forward pass through the model each
of these examples and repeat this to how
many components you want to study so now
that depends on granularity if you're
just looking at outputs of layers that's
not so bad if you want to do something
at the level of individual neurons or a
very big model that might become
might become worse
um with respect to different model sizes
sparsity I think we see all the time but
I don't think we've Quantified it or
anyone has Quantified it to see if it
differs in in different models so I
don't have a good answer to that I would
say that for some of the it depends on
your capability for some linguistic
capabilities you need to have
sufficiently strong models to even study
that so you can't really study that
across many uh scales but sparsity
somehow shows up everywhere
on your red rose example could you go
over again how you find out what the rep
where the representation of red rose is
oh yes how do you like figure out where
to change things yeah I didn't say and
that's not so a coincidence
um in fact in this work on uh on editing
the text to image models
um we decided so we tried using causal
mediation analysis to find the place
where it's stored and you can get these
parts they're not as clean as in the
language models that that I've shown I'm
not sure exactly why and because they
were not so clean we couldn't really
exactly detect
um we decided to kind of just take an
empirical approach so we had some
validation set
try this procedure of editing editing
some some parts on this validation
validation on different layers
layers on the tester so very empirical
driven
disappointing from an interpretability
perspective but that's what we had to do
to get this forward you just try
modifying it just try it in different
places
yeah and then how do you go from red to
blue you just see what you see what
happens right so we have these two
prompts a pack of roses and a pack of
blue roses
and the model processes these at some
point it generates representations for a
pack of roses
we make these representations look
similar to what they would have been if
the prompt had been a pack of blue roses
and once we have those representations
we up the way we make it is we change
some layers in the model we change some
weights
okay
so for in Neuroscience you know there
was a lot of excitement of these
grandmother neurons or Jennifer Aniston
neurons and then later it turned out
that actually they were not as like a
localized as people thought because they
just didn't look at enough negative data
to to detect that oh you know the
Jennifer Aniston neurons also fire on
you know bees or whatever
um how sure are you
are that these you know your your blue
roses are not screwing up something
completely different
yeah
um the extent that we crafted the data
set in the right way which I would say
is uh quite sure but not uh I wouldn't
bet my life but how are you like writing
a whole bunch of problems yeah we have
like other prompts so which are in the
neighborhood and we check if they had
changed something but I think the point
here something completely there's
something really fun yeah so we do
evaluate the general image generation
capabilities of the model you might take
like just a data set of ten thousand uh
prompts and generate images from our
edited model in the Baseline model you
measure the difference between the
distributions with fid it's about the
same so uh and to that extent we are
kind of uh confident yeah
okay
[Applause]